pas sur la gauche a pas d'eau
c'est bon
l'enquêté seuls tout ça ouais
alarme enfin la voix il est compagnon
n'a pas l'effet grand voix de ce que
marc chabot est vague car deschamps
avoue néanmoins que cela sur fond fine
deschamps arrive à moi j'étais sur quoi
le pc world soul
battez pas vous regardez moi un plan
large très large à gauche joies de la
montagne du grand rond bling et plans
très largement faille derrière la salle
et montagne derrière vous allez on va
les voir un peu on les voit un peu voilà
les doigts et c'est beau de descendre à
kuala attends tu vas aller tous bords d
aller vers la droite en baisse de 2 dans
de la main droite un peu l'image en
toile baisse de marquer dans la voix la
liste tu vas là dedans tu appuies après
être dans le noir et blanc
voilà c'est bassement en trouvant le
blanc plus dans le noir d'asie au monde
tourne entre l'ontt remonte remonte
montrera pas j'ai pris une grande
angoisse quand
1 tu traverses leblanc vas-y monte monte
monte au dessus et qu'il enlevait
directement sur un truc au dessus la
tête 1 kenzy monte monte monte dessus
dur avec lui tu meurs avec ce direct
tapas pirates écarter un peu il ya un
petit peu tout perd un peu blasé très
très beau l'attend à cela je veux que tu
avais tu peut écarter un peu là dedans
ben voila voila voila c'est super beau
ça va
ok voilà doucement tu dépenses
vers la gauche et tu remontes vers la
gauche par la culture aux montures mans
remonte datavance blanche qui est à
gauche la monte là tu la montée
d'arrivée sur le glacier voiture est
comme ça sur le noir c'est vachement
beau la belle a toujours du noir à
droite et un petit peu de blanc à gauche
aussi vachement beau ça voilà voilà
voilà voilà
bare bow wow tu peux tu peux descendre
un peu dans la matière que tu vois à
droite là moi ça c'est vachement pour
voir exactement ce que le cube passer à
une matière la inouïe là dedans voilà et
plus de 100 ans
matière d'une wars a envie du voile à
toi c'est noir noir ainsi perdu face à
foncer en train de fondre la tempête
c'est beau aurais tu vois que ça fonde
son angle loin avant la lan soir là
c'est super beau pour marquer la c doit
rentrer voilà c'est super bowl à l'oeil
c'est pas commencé sur l'écran mais
allez y c'est magnifique
pas content il
d'autre part comme ça bouge un très bon
les sens
ces poussées lacets blancs et noirs vont
pas encore plus que laurent blanc soit
tu regrettes a plus rien voilà précédent
- j'écarterai maintenant on va
s'éloigner un petit peu pour toi
peut-être du paysage pas s'éloigner un
petit peu pas s'éloigner un petit peu
maintenant en partant par la gauche
voilà ça durera ensuite des cartes tu
vas me devrait pouvoir voir les
montagnes derrière la montagne sont à
gauche le montagne soit go soit la rapée
animaux horizon là bas et coûte 0 2
reste redresse l'asie continue comme ça
quand tu es bien tourné il va le voir tu
veux rattraper voilà continue encore
bascule médicaux mêleront en bas tu vas
dans le dans la khl seule loi comme ça
voilà la honte à peu près dans la caisse
du monde de la montagne derrière voilà a
priori de rares et montagne derrière
dans l'ombre mais voilà l'horizon c'est
bon
elles n'ont pas là
ouvrir la porte arrière droit
toi
donc je descends voilà dans le gang de
gouda on est moche ou dix ans avant is
the wind de wimille ben woodside et
barbe bien qu'ils jouent dans la sphère
du bétail dans la glace belgrade est la
leur dans le très noir et très blanc ok
on va descendre un peu vite et est apte
à gauche la gauche voilà de tout pour
l'euro en entier pour le mois d août et
est à l'heure où sabrina godard
le rock est aussi longue et aussi bons à
12 mois à gossas concert au cerveau sa
gauche pour toi gauche à gauche à gauche
la gauche accord à gauche voilà ce visa
voire trop d'hambourg et a très bien
défendre aucun gars à battre a dit
également prêt d'argent avec les trucs
sous frank est ok ok les gars pas vos
bons plans
heureusement bras voilà maintenant d'en
faire un truc très oui qu'on vole pas
maintenant quand vous troquez parce
qu'on était tous à ok audard pendant
quatre jours ça devrait pas déranger
on va voir si on est peut-être que
windows windows 7
les androïdes avait bien rencontré
secteur broussailles à nac et guzet pour
le retour au soleil pointent pas le
faire seule à exposer et le néant de 2 à
0 contre bien on aura notre papa pour du
beurre dessus dans la foule horizon
twikin haïk et qui va avec une bouteille
et sucrées qui ne donne une référence
bien parce qu'il a raison parce que s'il
fait trouver le trou cet ouvrier devant
aux différences de diable
l'utilisateur
hop
cela dit ça va dépendre maintenant parce
que je suis je dorénavant les plans la
voix explique tout sourire transports
coûteux et peu et était entré à bègles
entre en tout cas c'est marrant parce
que soleil s'arrête net
ouais aller au delà de cette date
réglage peut relire tous les hivers la
texture a changé complètement si ce
qu'ils racontaient de travers ok bon
allez
pas la peine ok
tandis que ça